good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight in january of 2000 bill
clinton gave his final state of the
union address to the congress clinton
used that speech to push for dropping
trade barriers against the government of
china here's the argument he made
allowing china into the world trade
organization clinton promised america
that night would quote open china's
markets to the united states and quote
plainly advance the cause of peace in
asia and promote the cause of change in
china
in his last year in office clinton made
expanding the chinese economy one of his
most urgent priorities to do that he
appointed a lobbyist called steve
roshetti and put him in charge of the
project
fast forward to today china has been a
member of the world trade organization
for 20 years steve roshetti has risen
even higher in democratic politics he's
now a top white house aide to joe biden
as for china it has indeed changed as
bill clinton promised that it would
china is now the richest country in the
world its police state is far more
efficiently authoritarian even than it
was under chairman mao china is a much
graver threat to the united states and
to its neighbors we're as far from peace
in asia as we have been since 1945.
the american manufacturing sector
meanwhile is effectively gone it
evaporated along with millions of middle
class jobs most of the objects you buy
now are made in china
maybe you've seen the pictures of cues
of cargo ships strung out in the pacific
trying to get into american ports to
unload their containers
you will hear the scene described as
part of something called the global
supply chain but that intentionally
understates what it actually is what
you're looking at are america's supply
lines
at this point we're effectively an
outpost totally dependent on a far away
headquarters for the things we need to
live here's what it looks like
why so many empty shelves
u.s ports are backed up take a look at
this cargo ships sitting in the sea
waiting to pull into port it's causing
major u.s retailers like walmart home
depot and costco to target private cargo
ships in a rush to fill shelves for the
holiday season
on the roads there's a shortage of truck
drivers the white house says it's
addressing the issues fueled by covet 19
a labor shortage and increased demand
suddenly for the first time in
generations americans are having trouble
buying basic necessities the things they
need a new poll by rasmussen found that
62 percent of americans said they have
shortages in stores where they live
the things they can buy are suddenly
much more expensive
the labor department reporting wednesday
meats poultry fish and eggs increased a
combined 10.5 percent since september
2020. but it's not just food prices
skyrocketing the consumer price index
shows overall prices are up 5.4 percent
from a year ago more pain at the pumps
the national gas price rose a dollar
since last year aaa showing the average
price per gallon up from 218 in 2020 to
3.29
this year the social security
administration says inflation is why
nearly 70 million americans receiving
social security benefits will see a
nearly six percent increase in payments
next year the highest increase in four
decades
there are no signs that fundamentally
any of this is going to improve anytime
soon in fact on wednesday the
administration acknowledged that your
heating bills are likely to jump by more
than 50 percent this winter
those are the kind of things that people
actually notice it hurts when you get
poorer and many people are getting poor
but strangely the administration has
refused to acknowledge this if anything
they're celebrating it last night a
harvard professor called jason furman
who was closely aligned with the biden
white house sent this tweet quote most
of the economic problems we're facing
inflation supply chains etc are high
class problems we wouldn't have had them
if the unemployment rate was still 10
percent end quote
in other words you ought to be thrilled
to have less money it means we're
winning
ron clayne who is joe biden's chief of
staff at the white house promptly
endorsed that tweet
and that's delusional or maybe it's
intentional you pretend your failures
are victories and some people will
doubtless believe you that seem to work
in afghanistan maybe it'll work here
that could be their thinking
but it won't work here because domestic
economics is not like foreign policy
people notice when their own lives
change when you can't buy christmas
presents for your children or manage to
keep your house warm in january these
are not symbolic problems these are
measurable declines in your family's
standard of living and they have
consequences
if economic decline continues and it
seems likely to continue you will see a
profound political reset in this country
and here's why the only reason americans
have put up with the endless woke
garbage that the left turns out by the
gallon is because they can afford to put
up with it for generations this has been
a very rich country and affluence covers
a multitude of sins people will tolerate
a lot of things they disagree with as
long as gas is cheap and the amazon
deliveries keep coming
but when a society becomes poorer
people's attitudes change and they
change fast
for one thing they become much less
patient when they're mistreated you're
firing me right before christmas because
i won't take your shot no i'm resisting
that
you're telling me my son can't get a job
because he's the wrong skin color no
that's wrong and i'm going to fight it
etc etc
politics will look very different in a
country with permanent shortages and
this may be an unpleasant surprise for
the democratic party
the progressive left's entire program is
built on the presumption of endless
boundless affluence of course we can
afford that we're rich
people like nancy pelosi and sandy
cortez and rashida tilly believe that
and they believe it as a matter of faith
they talk about economics but they have
no idea how the actual economy works
they don't know anything about the great
american affluence machine they've never
really had jobs
the one thing they know for certain dead
certain is that every good thing must be
free it has to be
but that's not how life works certainly
not in countries that don't hold the
world's reserve currency there's a
reason they don't have drag queen story
hour in mexico
people in michoacan are worried about
tortilla prices and cartel shootings
they don't have time for that kind of
nonsense
we're about to become a lot more like
mexico
it turns out our economy was much more
fragile than we thought it was and if
we'd known that earlier we might not
have elected an economic illiterate like
joe biden as president
here's joe biden during the campaign
explaining to cnn anchors that actually
printing trillions of new dollars for
wasteful government social programs will
reduce inflation
if you're pumping all of this money
into the economy couldn't that add to no
look here's the deal moody's today when
a wall street firm not some liberal
think tank
said if we pass the other two things i'm
trying to get done we will in fact
reduce inflation
reduce inflation
reduce inflation because we're going to
be providing good opportunities and jobs
for people who in fact are going to be
reinvesting that money back in all the
things we're talking about
did i say the campaign
he was actually president when he said
that that was this june when he stood on
stage looked right into the camera and
told us that when you make more money
when you print more us dollars the value
of us dollars goes up
and then you watch the cnn anchors nod
like livestock it made sense to them
but of course it's ludicrous it's just
about every sane person has acknowledged
since inflation is rising because the
government has devalued the us dollar by
making too many u.s dollars they're like
sand now they're not worth much
but still the white house does not seem
concerned
pete but a judge has been on leave from
his job since august after adopting a
child paternity leave they call it
trying to figure out how to breastfeed
no word on how that went but now he's
back in office as the transportation
secretary and he's deeply amused he says
to see that dozens of container ships
can't get into this country
as we're looking at these supply chain
issues how bad are they going to get for
americans and i'm talking specifically
you know leading here into the december
holidays where people are relying on
getting goods on getting presents
well i think there's always been two
kinds of christmas shoppers there's the
ones who have all their list completed
by halloween and then there's people
like me who show up at the mall on
christmas eve if you're in that ladder
bucket obviously there's going to be
more challenges
kind of a funny little dorky dad story i
wait till the last minute to shop for
christmas that's not the point pete but
a judge the point is you're the
transportation secretary and our
transportation grid is broken and people
can't get christmas presents for their
kids or food that they want to eat or
things that they would like to buy our
shelves are empty is that a problem no
it's kind of amusing
the deeper truth is that people can't
get consumer goods because we're too
dependent on china because our leaders
outsourced all of our production to a
foreign country and now they're joking
about it and they want you to believe
that's a good thing
and because they want you so badly to
believe it's a good thing their allies
in the media are repeating that message
verbatim
so um i talked to kai risdall last night
who explained to me about the supply
chain yes it is terrible people want to
get their things but it's also an
indicator that the economy is doing well
people want to buy things
and that it's backed up so let's look at
the part that hey the economy is great
people can buy things again they're out
and about they want to buy gas it's you
know okay fine i know i think that's a
little spin well it is it is spin i'm
just trying to make people feel good
we're not making the case for
credentials or expertise
just because someone teaches at harvard
doesn't mean he's wise or even smart but
when you open your segment on economics
by saying i talked to a public radio
host who does a show with the word
economics in the title and here's what i
learned
[Laughter]
you're not trying very hard
especially when his conclusion is
inflation is a measure of our success be
grateful you can no longer afford to eat
meat you're doing your part for climate
change things are going to change if
this continues
you can believe that hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else